you know Sydney Australia just began the
new year with its world-renowned
fireworks display but the country is in
the middle of an unprecedented wildfire
crisis right now and a lot of people say
it's the wrong time to be celebrating
look at this
very scary scene at a beach where
thousands of people have gone to escape
the flames now this is southwest of
Sydney some people were told her
actually running into the sea under a
glowing red sky me and Lee is in London
Ian I wonder what were officials saying
to those who said hey listen hold off on
the fireworks not the right time to do
it yeah good morning a large parts of
Australia are currently in a total fire
ban as the country continues to burn but
Sydney was able to get an exemption as
you can see to go ahead with its
firework show Australia's Prime Minister
supports the decision saying the event
shows his country's resilience while
others cited the money it generates for
the economy but not everyone is going on
going in on this celebration Sydney is
one of the first major cities in the
world to ring in the New Year
and it does so with a bang but thousands
say this iconic fireworks display should
have been called off I think that should
just band up just for this year Wow this
is all happening just leave it a year
and do it again next year I think the
money should be going to the fireese and
the bush and also the people in the
country towns Australia is facing one of
its worst wildfire seasons ever
prompting more than two hundred and
seventy-five thousand people to sign a
petition to cancel the show saying
cities like Sydney that are already
choking and smog from fires didn't need
any more smoke in its air the petition
also asked that the millions being spent
on fireworks should have gone towards
the army of firefighters battling the
flames that have destroyed 1,000 homes
and to protect the country's devastated
wildlife like some koalas who are in
danger of losing up to 30% of their
habitat fireworks are clearly an
ignition source for wildfires
associate professor Matthew herd oh who
studies climate and fires praises parts
of the US that have canceled their own
displays out of caution an unlikely risk
in Sydney but by defying Australia's
total fire ban her doe says it sends the
wrong message
as the climate continues to change them
we need to consider that maybe we need
to forego things like firework displays
especially when wild fire danger is high
in part because that can give people the
perception that it's okay to light off
fireworks and there is no relief in
sight for Australia as the fires
continue to range and that has thousands
living with the uncertainty of whether
they'll have a home to go to back to in
the new year Jericka in Lee in London
forest thank you
you